[Music]
foreign
so the opening question for three
minutes that I'll first pose to Sam
Coleman is is it a fundamental mistake
to think that the world and
Consciousness are purely material Sam
thank you thanks Joanna
um I don't think it's a mistake at all
but I do think that we don't understand
the material very well I think that
physics and science really only tell us
so much I think at the moment in trying
to explain Consciousness scientifically
we're a bit like people trying to
recreate a beautiful colorful oil
painting like the Mona Lisa using uh
pencil and paper we just don't have the
right resources
um so Neuroscience deals in action
potentials right Action potentials are
what our senses our nose ears eyes
produce when they do their thing and
convert light or sound into signals that
are ready to be processed and turned
into Sensations in different parts of
the brain
um
by the way sensation or feeling
something that's really all I mean by
Consciousness right you've got it uh the
chair you're sitting on doesn't have it
presumably a rock doesn't have it many
animals have got it probably leeches
don't have it that's all I really mean
by Consciousness but also so so folks
think about the difference between uh
Smelling Coffee tasting uh something
else tasting lemon seeing a sunset
smelling a rose there's just no way that
different frequencies of of
electrochemical activity in the brain
which is really all that goes on could
explain those differences it's as if I
had a a factory with the same Machinery
in it and by plonking it down in
different places it's suddenly just by
virtue of that produced radically
inexplicably different things like
marshmallows over here tanks over there
the the the the sensory the the neural
apparatus of your different sensory
areas in your brain is made of much the
same Machinery it's just no way that uh
the fact that they're in different
places makes the difference between
tasting Peach seeing a sunset smelling a
rose what's the answer we could get rid
of Consciousness altogether which is
what I think a neuroscience-based
approach ultimately does or it it
downgrades it so much that it's pretty
much like getting rid of it like or
doing Pepsi and being given Coke but
like actually worse than that like the
Neuroscience based account of
Consciousness is just not the real thing
or we could do what Donald recommends
and make Consciousness into everything
that exists but then I just don't know
how we know that we aren't alone in the
universe how we know there's anyone else
to talk to we might just be an empty
mind in a big empty Universe mind you is
something else right I think philosophy
can kind of supplement science to give
us that extra something that Mata needs
to produce a conscious mind out of a
brain to give us a more colorful if you
like enriched picture of the matter to
explain how you get Consciousness in a
material world what's the extra
something else well uh different options
maybe maybe matter itself has a
conscious aspect or maybe it has
something that is closely related to but
less than Consciousness but when you put
it together in the right way it gives us
Consciousness I think something like
that anyway is going to be the way to
understand Consciousness in a material
universe thanks very much Sam that's
great I'll now pose the same question to
Donald Hoffman
um for three minutes Donald is it a
fundamental mistake to think that the
world and Consciousness are purely
material thank you
so by material I think of objects in
space and time
and physicists such as David Gross and
Nima arkani Hamid are now telling us
that space-time is doomed by that they
mean space-time is not fundamental
and they're not just throwing up their
hands and giving up the physicists have
now found structures Beyond space-time
like the positive grossmanian the
amplitudehedron and there so this this
is all new that's only been in the last
10 years that they've for example had
the amplitohedron but the idea that
space and time and objects like um
bosons leptons and quarks particles and
so forth are fundamental is now no
longer the received opinion um there's
something deeper like the amplitahedron
and beyond that something called
decorative permutations and so so the
idea of reductionism is also doomed
according to physicists like name or
Connie Ahmed the idea that as we go to
smaller and smaller scales in space and
time we find more and more fundamental
laws and more and more fundamental
entities that's also dead so so I'm not
a pan psychist in the sense that I don't
want to try to put Consciousness in the
elementary particles because the the
physicists themselves tell us that
space-time and the so-called Elementary
particles are doomed we have to go
entirely outside of space-time and and
trying to put Consciousness inside of
particles or behind particles we have we
have to have a much deeper framework now
evolution by natural selection also
agrees this is work that I've done with
some of my colleagues it also agrees
that um our perceptions of space and
time are not an insight into the nature
of reality they're they're merely an uh
an interface an artifact of our of our
perceptual sensory systems
there's a technical question what is the
probability that Evolution would shape
sensory systems to see any aspect of the
structure of reality as it is and it
turns out the probability is precisely
zero that any sensory system has ever
been shaped to see any aspect of the
structure of objective reality so
Evolution and the physicists agree
space-time is doomed and and
reductionism is doomed and so we have to
look for Theory Of Consciousness outside
of it and and I would agree with with
Sam that solipsism is not the answer
either we we needed a theory of
Consciousness that's not so upsistic
thank you Donald that's great Hannah can
I turn to you then in terms of what
Donald's saying and you've written a
book on Consciousness so firstly this
question of how you're defining
Consciousness and I was also really
interested in Donald saying he's worked
on these neural correlates and his
question is
um do they really give rise to
Consciousness and whether you could also
look at that too that that question of
the the particular phraseology as well
so if we think of the idea of
Consciousness as our ability to form an
individual unique sense of reality
that's based on our experiences but also
the genes that have been given to us
from our mum and dad which also then
includes Donald's discussion on
Evolution
um and also his idea on the the
importance of the microtubules as well
so basically within each of our brains
we have this wonderful neural circuitry
that connects up 86 billion nerve cells
into this circuit board of around 100
trillion connections as we learn things
from our environment as we take in
information from the outside world and
we solidify them within our circuit
board what happens is that there's a new
connection that forms from one nerve
cell to another nerve cell so that's
something as we learn in our environment
this is what we see in the brain as
we're learning things as we um consider
consolidate that learn thing into a
memory that becomes a stable connect
connection within the mind and so it can
become a fast route of information
transfer across that very complex
intricate circuit board and each of us
have a very individual cartography a
very individual circuit board within our
mind based on our experiences and also
the genes that we're given from our mum
and dad and that's what creates our very
individual sense of reality our very
individual perception of the world so
there's some lovely research that's come
out of Christopher and uterus Labs at
University College London where they've
basically taken different individuals
and asked them about their sense of
reality about the world and because we
all take shortcuts in information
processing so each each of us use about
20 of our daily energy quota in order to
send those electric signals whizzing
across our very individual circuit board
within our mind to create our sense of
reality but we each take little
shortcuts because our brain is so busy
creating this up-to-date sense of
reality that it has to make use our pre
previous experiences in order to make
assumptions and so what they found in
the lab is that when you bring together
different people
um and ask them about their sense of
reality and ask them to discuss freely
discuss their sense of reality then
they're much more likely to get towards
a more accurate representation of
reality because they're balancing out
any bias
um any kind of errors that are coming up
in that individual sense of perception
of the world so really what's important
is our Collective Consciousness not the
individual Consciousness because we're
each individually deeply flawed because
of the energy metabolism within our
brain thank you that's really
interesting in this sense as well of the
individuals Within These wider terms you
know that there are many many
consciousnesses I think we'll talk about
that later as well because I know Donald
has a theory that also um relates to
that
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas